>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David Plylar: Good
evening everybody.
My name is David Plyler.
I'm a music specialist at
the Library of Congress.
And it is my pleasure to speak
with you this evening primarily
about Schumann, and
in particular,
a work that we don't
get to hear too often.
I know it will be a wonderful
treat for me to be able
to hear this tonight by a
pianist like Richard Goode.
So I know you're
all in for a treat,
not only with the solo piano
work, the "the "but also the
"Second Piano Trio" of Schumann
and the "Second Piano
Quartet" of Brahms.
But we will focus mostly
on the solo piano piece
and some interesting ways in
which it interfaces with Brahms
in particular, not necessarily
the piece that we're going
to hear tonight, but the young
Brahms who came to know Schumann
through his early piano music.
One thing to note about Schumann
is that he tended to work
in spurts on particular
types of genres.
So the 1830s were
primarily focused
on the writing for solo piano.
In fact, the first 23 published
opuses are solo piano music.
And then we shift
into lieder, art song.
In fact, in 1840, he writes
over half of his lieder output,
so 140-ish songs in one
year, 13 months or so.
And then he moves onto chamber
music and whatnot in 1842,
especially in 1847, and tries
his on other larger works
like symphonic works and
opera and things like that.
Some of those things
went well for him.
Some did not.
Firstly, I just want
to check and see.
How many of you know
the "Humoreske?"
And I'm just going to
call it "Humoresque" just
to Anglophy [phonetic] it here.
So several people but
maybe not a lot of people
in the audience are really
familiar with this work.
And I think that's a shame
because it's a real gem.
And I think there are
certain reasons why it is not
as well-known as one
would like it to be.
And I'll talk about a few of
those in the course this talk.
But first, I wanted to read
to you just a little bit
of what kind of criticism
was being written
about Schumann's work at the
time, while he was alive.
And this comes from 1844,
I believe in a translation
by Susan Gillespie of
Karl Kasmalle [phonetic].
And he has, I think, a
very modern way of looking
at criticism and
what it should be.
Karl writes, "One of
the most difficult tests
of the aesthetic
philosopher will always be
to express musical effects
in words, to use paraphrase
to explain and give
recognizable form
to what is indescribable
and immaterial.
Whatever most intelligent, fine,
and well considered thoughts
he may offer in this case,
they will always appear
imperfect, inadequate, cold,
and forced compared
with their subjects.
But this will not deter us
from at least making attempts
to sketch the impression that
the "Humoreske" made on us.
Even if the results should
be nothing but a half measure
and an imprecise one at
that, if the sketch turns
out to be a purely subjective
product of individual emotion
if we ourselves depart
in our interpretation
from the actual intentions
of the composer,
we will find solace in the
general lot of commentators
who are often clever when it
comes to discovering a number
of things that the artist, in
the rush of emotions and fired
with enthusiasm,
has unconsciously
incorporated into his work.
But on the other hand, may also
fail to notice other things
that the artist inserted
into the work
with full awareness
and clear intent.
In addition, it is
quite conceivable
that there could be several
different interpretations
of the same work, each one
eminently sensible, appropriate,
intelligent, and capable as it
were, of opening some new door
to understanding and
providing the key
to hitherto hidden
secrets of the spirit."
So I read a rather
long quote from that
because oftentimes criticism,
especially music criticism,
tends to look at very specific
things that people value
as here's something
that somebody did well.
This is an example of great
counterpoint or something
like that, or worse, here's an
example of bad counterpoint,
here's a case where
Schumann failed in this.
Like this is a kind of a
common trope with discussions
of Schumann's orchestration,
in particular.
It would be interesting to
have had that conversation
with Schumann at the
time he was writing
and see just how far
our conceptions might be
from what he was
actually going for.
But back to the "Humoreske."
This work is a very long one.
It's some 25 to 30 minutes
depending on who's playing it.
It's ostensibly in a
single movement but has well
over 20 different tempo
markings and changes in tempo,
and that's not counting the
types of gradual changes
that you get with accelerandi
and retards and things
like that.
So how does he manage all that
time that passes in one swoop?
Other composers down the
road later than those --
15 years later, 13 years
later, for instance Liszt,
would write a single
movement piano sonata
that is clearly divided
into subsections, say,
three major ones, although
that's debatable too.
In the case of "The Humoreske,"
we have so many different
divisions that it runs the risk
of being just a hodge-podge
of ideas that are just kind
of presented willy-nilly.
So how is it that
Schumann manages this?
One of the things that he
does is uses what I'm calling
musical landmarks.
You might think this is similar
to what you might find in, say,
a rondo structure in which
you have a single idea
that comes back time and again
and it serves as kind of a way
to re-orient to familiar
territory.
We don't have exactly
that happening
but what we have
are blocks of time
in which Schumann will book-end
a section with a familiar idea.
So, for instance, the
very opening serves
as sort of an introduction.
And roughly five or
six minutes later,
we have that same material
is kind of referenced again
in a look back before moving on.
That looking back is something
that's going to be important
in a little bit when I speak
about Brahms' relationship this
piece in particular in speaking
of his third Piano Sonata in
F Minor, the Opus 5 piece,
that has five movements,
including one
that is literally
a backward glance.
The fourth movement
is a backwards glance
at earlier material.
Another way that
Schumann manages
to hold things together is by
making kind of simple ideas
that don't have to be presented
in the same form every
time that you hear them.
So for instance, on the
left you'll see a baseline
that has a particular
rhythm that pops
out when you listen to it.
You'll hear it all
over the place.
In fact, it pervades this entire
large section of the piece.
Then we have some
40 measures later.
We have a triad.
In the left hand,
you'll see this.
It's doing the same rhythm
but it's no longer
melodically important in terms
of the relationship
that matters.
It's the rhythmic one.
Schumann gets to that point by
first isolating a single note
and repeating it, and then
doing a third and repeating that
and then finally doing a
triad and repeating that.
And these types of little
things that are catchy
and familiar help to link
different sections that may
or may not have other types
of musical material in common.
Just to start getting into the
relationship between Brahms
and Schumann in this particular
piece, I wanted to point
out what I see as a clear
relationship between the type
of the gesture that
Schumann would do.
Again, this is in 1839, versus
what Brahms would do in, say,
1853 when he is still young
and trying to impress Schumann.
A good way to do that is
to write like your mentor.
Just to illustrate this example,
let's hear track 2 starting
at 426, and this
should be the example
that you see on the left.
[ Music ]
The thing I want you
to notice there is
that you have two
iterations of this idea.
You hear them into
different registers.
You hear what are
marked as triplets.
You hear that and kind
of the middle register
on the right-hand.
And then you hear them an
octave lower in the left-hand.
Jumping up about 14 years to
Brahms' First Piano Sonata,
let's listen to track 13, 121.
[ Music ]
So the types of things
that you'll see here,
it's more exaggerated
in the case of Brahms.
He thinks, even though
there are many similarities
between the way that
Brahms and Schumann write,
they actually have very distinct
personalities at the keyboard.
And in this case, Brahms
is taking greater use
of registerable [phonetic]
differentiation.
But you'll see these types
of pairs of ideas coming back
at kind of conditional
transitional moments.
And I think what's
interesting about it is
that it shows how both composers
are thinking about the piano
in an orchestral
way and I don't mean
like they're assigning the
viola to this one or that,
but they're actually
orchestrating for the piano,
recognizing the timbre
[phonetic] advantages
and disadvantages
of different ways
of setting the musical material.
All the best piano
composers today
and all the way back
were very aware
of what the possibilities
were, especially register wise.
What other kind of
point of junction
between the young Brahms
and the older Schumann comes
in the way of familiar textures.
And what becomes
striking to me is
that Schumann is essentially
a really progressive composer
who's writing stuff that,
even now, I am fascinated
by the complexity and the
depth of what he is doing.
Brahms, on the other hand, I'm
also fascinated by everything
that he does, but he
tends to not to put it all
out on a limb like
Schumann does.
But you do find in early
Brahms that he takes some
of what Schumann is doing
and tries to manipulate it
in his own way in his own music.
In particular, I thinking of --
just to give you an example --
we'll look at the opening of
the "Humoreske," the movement
in "Der Nacht" from
[Inaudible] the Opus 12,
which is a little bit
earlier in the late 1830s.
And then the Fourth Ballade
of Brahms is Opus 10.
So first let's take a listen
to just the opening of track 1.
[ Music ]
This kind of material, there we
hear it in a very slow fashion,
but basically featuring
broken arpeggios,
that kind of give us a sense
of the harmonic rhythm,
is something that we
find throughout the
"Humoreske," all throughout it.
So that's something
to be aware of.
Let's go back to
the "In Der Nacht."
This is in the central section.
This is track 14.
[ Music ]
What do you start to notice in
these types of accompaniments is
that the accompaniment itself
has a certain crunch to it
in terms of harmonically it
has some distance in there,
and it competes with
the melodic statements.
Skip ahead to Brahms.
This is going to be the Fourth.
He wrote a set of four Ballades.
And in some ways, they're
among his more experimental
early works.
And this was his Opus 10, so
let's listen to the opening
and then the section
at track 15.
[ Music ]
So would you go home and sing
that tune to somebody, you know,
after hearing it once?
Probably not.
And this is one of the things
that makes these
particular types of kind
of coloristic settings really
interesting in the young Brahms
and the more mature Schumann
at the time, because they start
to explore harmony and just
kind of atmosphere in a way
that wouldn't really be
done again until later
in the 19th century, and of
course in the 20th century.
It's not at the expense
of melodic material.
It's just that it seems to be
subsumed, often with the conceit
of some contrapuntal types
of activity going on,
especially [inaudible]
canonic activity
or just imitative
gestures in general.
So that's what I mean by
familiar textures in terms
of this period of 1839
Schumann and early 1850s Brahms.
Now we get to a very interesting
subject for tonight that has
to do with several of the
pieces on the program.
We often talk about quotation
and music and we seem
to know what we're
talking about.
But there's speculation as
to whether or not things
that we identify as quotations
would've been perceived
as such back in the time.
One of the more famous ones
that a really great speaker
that we had, a scholar -- she
won a Mendelssohn scholar.
Larry Todd has written about
is the allusion to [Inaudible]
in the Schumann fantasy.
That's a critical reception
that did not have any legs to it
until the 20th century.
So it's one of those
things that we accept
and we see this being there
but it may or may not have been
in terms of what that means.
So it might be something that's
more meaningful for the receiver
than it is necessary
for the composer.
But let's take a look at some
examples of obvious quotes.
So Schumann's Opus 2 is
his first big collection
of concerti pieces
that go together.
Each one is very
short little piece
and has a very specific
character is a character
piece intimates.
He continues to write in this
small character piece form
for a long time.
I mean, he puts in a smattering
of sonatas here and there,
but he's mostly writing
these small character pieces.
By the time he gets
to "Carnaval" his Opus
9, he's quoting himself.
And what's funny about this is
that he literally
is writing it -
this is the Florestan
movement from "Carnaval."
There's a passage that feels
exactly like the "Papillion"
that you see on the left,
but he just keeps going.
And he thinks better of it
and it's like "Papillion"
and he actually writes in there
"Papillion" with
a question mark.
And that's the end of the score,
so it's a very obvious quote,
but it makes you think is he
just thinking of this on the fly
as he's writing this music?
And it's very interesting.
I think, just so you
can get a kind of sense
of this fleeting
reminiscence of something
that has a very specific
meaning,
let's just hear what we're going
to be listening for,
which is number 8.
Just the opening.
[ Music ]
Just play number
9 then let it go.
[ Music ]
So you literally have a change
in, it's not just a quote
within the context, is a
literal change of tempo,
change of everything, just to
make this reference very clear.
So that's one that a given,
because Schumann writes it --
we know that one for that one.
For the next one, this is one
that's a generally accepted one
as a quote in the Piano Trio
that you're going
to hear tonight.
In the first movement,
kind of once you get
to the second major area, you
hear something that sounds
like the intermezzo
from "Liederkreis,"
from Schumann's song cycle
"Liederkreis" Opus 39.
I neglected to bring an example
of this song unfortunately,
but you can hear the
combination of this
if we go to track 16, 145.
You'll at least hear the melody
as you would hear
it in the song.
It's pretty close, at least
the first seven notes.
[ Music ]
And then we had the
imitation going on.
This is a [inaudible]
active piece, Schumann's.
But one of the points that I
want to bring up is that, okay,
if we accept that this is
a quotation, if we accept
that he wants us to think,
oh, I know his song cycle
from X number of years ago,
from 1840, seven years past.
I'm so familiar with Schumann's
work will make this connection
and I'll know what the words
are that are being spoken of
and then it will have a
different sort of meaning to me.
That's one way to look at it.
The other question is how much
of the referent do you take?
I've bracketed the sections
that are not included
in the quoted part.
So you see, it's a little
bit of a fluffy translation.
But the "I hold in
my depths of heart,"
that component is bracketed
because it's not
actually quoted.
But you don't need to
put an entire symphony
to reference a symphony, right?
But the question is then, does
it extend to the song itself?
Does it extend just
to the phrase?
Does it extend to the cycle?
Where does it stop and what is
actually meaningful about it?
I don't know the answer to that,
but that's the kind of question
that I like to ask whenever
there's a quotation,
especially one that feels --
sometimes we feel ones
that might be frivolous
or somebody is just
airing something and trying
to make us hear it that way.
But it is pretty darn close.
It could very well be
an intentional one.
You know, composers have,
especially in tonal music,
have a reservoir of material
that they're working with and,
you know, if you're going to
write a scale, there's only
so many ways to do it before
you're going to be starting
to refer to that other scale
that you wrote, you know.
So there are things like that to
think about and you have to see
where they are in a
piece, the importance given
to the context, and
things like that.
I'm going to give you an
example of a speculative quote.
Schumann wrote the "Humoreske"
while he was in Vienna
and he had two other pieces
and had two other pieces
that he wrote around
the same time,
on one of which is
the "Arabesque."
And there's this moment towards
the end of the "Humoreske"
where he starts to move
into a different material
that we haven't heard before.
And let's listen to that.
This is track 6, 35.
[ Music ]
And then, listen to the
opening of the "Arabesque,"
which is written
about the same time.
Track 10.
[ Music ]
So if you were to compare those
- I didn't engrave these ones
for you, but if you were to
compare them side by side,
would see certain
traits that they share,
especially the little
grace notes
and the ornaments
and things like that.
But they don't look
exactly the same.
It's rather the affect
that they create,
it seems to be part
of the same world.
And I think it's most likely
that it's just something that's
in Schumann's ear at the time
and that's the kind
of stuff he's ready.
I don't know that it's
a direct, we're supposed
to think arabesque and then have
that mean something different.
But it does conjure
up that other world,
which might insight us
to go and actually listen
to that other piece, which is
-- if we happen to know it,
that's another problem.
If you know these
pieces, if you're going
to get the references.
Then we get to a very special
moment in the "Humoreske"
that most people aren't aware
of unless you look at the music.
And this is where
Schumann actually puts
in hidden messages.
A lot of people know the
stories about "Carnaval"
with the sphinxes, where they
are written out spellings
of initials, of names,
and things like that.
That's one type of thing,
but what Schumann does in the
"Humoreske" is he actually
writes out a melody
that you're not supposed
to hear,
or rather that you're supposed
to be imagining as
an inner voice.
What we see -- this is
second [inaudible] hastily,
the part that says
[Foreign Language]
that basically means
inner voice.
You can't play it and it keeps
going for I think 24 measures
or something like that.
So your right hand
plays the top part
and your left hand
plays the bottom staff,
and there's some sort of
psychological process going
on in which you're
imagining that middle line.
Sometimes you have certain
things as you come through
and you do hear some
things actually
because they are articulated.
You also might be tricking
ourselves into hearing it.
But this is what is often
called music for the eye.
So let's just hear
what this sounds like,
just the opening of track 2.
[ Music ]
Very beautiful music, and
doesn't need the inner melody
in terms of meeting
another voice.
But one could imagine singing
it or having it in your ear
and you are articulating
it in certain ways.
If you look at the left-hand,
you will see that that D,
for instance, is
playing on the off beats.
So you do here that
D in some context.
But not with the particular
markings that Schumann puts in.
He actually has crescendi and
things like that with this voice
that you're not supposed
to hear.
He has accents on a
couple of the notes.
So this is a very strange
concept and kind of comes
to this idea of why do we
call this a humoresque.
Why would he call it this?
Is it because he thought it
was very humorous and whatnot?
It has a lot of depth, this
piece, and a lot of angst in it.
But it does have
moments of humor.
And I think that that humor
is a type of musical irony
in that it sets up certain
types of expectations
and then flips them
on their head
so that we have juxtaposed
things
that we wouldn't
normally put together.
And then he plays these
sort of poetic tricks.
He was also a very
talented writer.
And so he has these
sorts of equivalence
in a musical sense
that he puts here.
And this would be the same as
like when you're reading a poem
and it's in the shape
of something.
If you are being read this poem
and it's in the shape of a heart
or something, you're not going
to know that it's in the shape
of a heart unless you're looking
at it as you're reading it.
And that's the kind
of analogous thing
that Schumann was doing here.
Then he flips it and I don't
know how many people comment
on this, but what's interesting
is there's this really beautiful
moment of repose that comes
a bit later in this section
where what you see
doesn't tell you much,
but what you hear is
related to the baseline
of what we just heard.
So let's give this a
listen, 246 of track 2.
[ Music ]
And let's just hear the
beginning of tract 2 again,
just to you can hear again.
Just listen to the base.
[ Music ]
So what's kind of popping
out is something that's going
to be cleared to somebody
if they follow the
peddling directions,
which is not always going to
be the case with pianists,
and if they're really thinking
about how this is related
to other parts of the piece.
So it really requires a very
thoughtful pianist to be able
to pull this kind of a
work off because you have
to have the visual
things happening
and also the aural
things happening.
That sounds like a
pretty empty statement
because pianists all should be
doing that all the time, right?
At the same time there's the
care with which he does this
that I think is quite
fascinating.
So in what way does Brahms
interact with this sort of play
on what we're supposed to hear
and what we think
we're supposed to hear?
Well, I found one in particular,
and this is related again
to the Third Piano Sonata and in
particular the first movement,
that I want credit for if
anybody wants to run with this.
Basically one of the things
that happens when you talk
about musical information
theory, you have sets
of expectations that you put
forward and then you either live
up to them or you don't.
And the less that
you live up to them,
for more information
you're providing.
It's too scattered, you're
not going to be able to kind
of partake of whatever
is being conveyed to you.
But if it's different enough to
where it becomes interesting,
that's when we have perhaps good
music and a cultural context
that has certain patterns
that it recognizes.
That's all to say that
if you play a tune
and if you keep it going and
it goes the same way for most
of the piece, the times that
you deviate become important.
So let's just hear the
opening of tract 13.
[ Music ]
Everybody's awake now.
One of the things that
[inaudible] a second area
that has a triple pattern
that keeps getting repeated,
but what we hear here is this
very clear dum-da-da-dum.
And it's that "dum,"
the second one,
that is very important
accented as you can see.
And that plays a big role
in the entire movement
of this really great piece.
Gradually, Brahms plays a
trick that composers do,
where they will slow something
down, maybe extend things a bit,
augment the durations so that it
has the same basic sound to it
but it feels like
it naturally fits.
And what Brahms does
is he eventually slows
down to the point where
you expect to hear
that dum-da-da-dum,
that last part,
and potentially you
might be feeling it
in your head even
though it's not there.
And so, I'll show
you what I mean.
A little bit later in the piece,
we start to have this kind
of an offbeat thing in the
right hand, and we have an idea
of that motive in the left
hand that's just partial.
And I swear that you start
to hear the resolution
of this idea.
So see what you think.
This is track 13, 713.
[ Music ]
So if I had started that
a little bit earlier,
it even makes it
a bit more clear.
But he actually eventually
starts to put it in there
which makes you think that
either the pianist missed it,
they missed the notes they
were supposed to play earlier,
or maybe it was partially there.
And so this is, I feel, I
have no way to prove this,
but I think it's a case in which
Brahms is playing with this idea
of expectation and what
you're supposed to hear
and what you actually hear.
And I think that he
learns that from Schumann.
Going back to Schumann in the
types of kind of musical plays
on words that he would do,
he'll turn an accompanimental
[phonetic] figures
into dual role types
of materials.
Kind of [inaudible]
between purposes.
So in this section which is
kind of an intimate section,
you'll see those little
dotted bracket parts are kind
of secondary ideas disk, just
kind of [inaudible] ideas
but they occasionally line
up with the melodic ideas.
And this is kind of a way
that he threads things
together very craftily.
See what you think.
This is track 4.
[ Music ]
And by the way, this is one of
those bookends kind of sections
that comes upon either
end of a larger section.
But what you see especially
towards the end where you have
that rising scale
that turns into,
this is just continuing
the scale and it turns
into melodic scale as opposed
to just an accompanimental
[phonetic] one.
This type of inner voice
work is highly characteristic
of Schumann's piano
writing and also a Brahms,
and I feel this is also
where Brahms gets a lot
of that inspiration for
writing in that manner.
As I get to the close
here, this is going
to be a bit more speculative
than where I was before.
Schumann has a lot of
self-awareness, I feel,
in his music, like
other composers do.
You have Richard Strauss,
who referred to his own music
in other pieces and
many others too.
But Schumann seems to be
dealing with a vat of material
that comes back always
in a creative guise,
always in a new set of trappings
but still feels like it's
from the same kind of
font of creativity.
And I just wanted to share
a couple examples that come
from towards the end
of the "Humoreske."
And what I see this as
is kind of a moment,
again just this isolated -- it
actually happens three times
in a row -- of this isolated
idea just before the very end
of the piece.
And then I want to show
you an earlier work
where he does something
similar, and then a later work
where he does something similar.
So this is the last gesture
that you actually hear,
but you actually hear
this three times.
Let's listen to track 6, 532.
[ Music ]
And then there's sort
of this just wonderful,
very brief fast coda
that ends the piece.
But I'm not going
to show you that.
You'll get to hear
that in a little bit.
Rather, have that in the back
of your minds, and if we go back
to the 'Kinderszenen,"
Opus 15, number 8.
Let's just play the
opening of that, track 11.
Yeah, just the opening.
[ Music ]
Okay, so that's a much faster
setting of the material.
It may or may not sound
immediately like the other one,
but what you'll start to notice
as you listen to more and more
of Schumann's music is
that he starts to kind
of have the same sorts of
gestures that he'll draw on.
And sometimes it's faster music
and sometimes it's slower music.
We won't listen to another
slower one but let's listen
to what he does in "Waldscenen."
As I said at the beginning of
this talk, Schumann wrote most
of his piano music that
everybody knows in the 1830s.
He started to write more some
didactic works and things
like that for his daughters in
the 1840s, and then he came back
to writing some character
pieces.
And one of the great sets
of late Schumann is the
"Waldscenen," the
"Forest Scenes."
I didn't include the opening
movement but that's one
where the repose is
just magnificent.
But let's hear the sixth
movement, just the opening.
This is track 12.
[ Music ]
So what you might notice and all
of these things is a
rising scale followed
by a descending one.
Sometimes there at
the same pitch level.
Sometimes they're not.
But it's all kind of a
gestural [inaudible] contour
that Schumann would draw from.
And writing a lot
of this often joyful
and very thoughtful
reflective kinds of music.
I think that when you're
listening to all the pieces
and then the trio that
also not many people know,
the "F Major Trio," Opus
80, is a magnificent piece.
And I think you're
really going to enjoy
that if you haven't
heard that before.
That's also a [inaudible] piece.
I just don't have the
time to really go into it.
The "Humoreske" you're
going to enjoy
if you haven't heard it before.
There are lots of melodies
that might seem familiar to you
if you haven't heard the piece.
Again, I think because of the
sort of communal dramatic pot
from which Schumann draws.
And, of course, the Brahms
quartet is a very important work
for Brahms because it
signifies in many ways a part
of his maturity written
about back to back
with the first piano
quartet, the G minor,
after Schumann was gone.
But we have Brahms
coming of age.
I think it's interesting and I
would encourage you to go back
and listen to early Brahms, and
some of these Schumann cycles,
just to see how they're kind
of feeding off of each other,
or rather Brahms is
feeding off of Schumann,
but in a very positive way.
So in particular the
Opus 10 Ballades.
Also the Opus 1,
2, and 4, and 5.
The Opus 1 and 2 and 5 are piano
sonatas and Opus 4 is a scherzo.
And you can really
find the Schumann
in these early Brahms works
and they're really rewarding.
So thanks so much, and
if you have any questions
that I could try to
answer, I'd be happy to.
[ Applause ]
>> I was interested in
the hidden messages.
That bar of music that
isn't really played.
Does any other composer do that?
>> David Plylar: Well,
you know, they do.
People do.
It more often happens
with text being inserted.
So to answer firstly from
a musical standpoint,
lots of heavily contrapuntal
music will often have this sort
of implied voice that comes
through that we might imagine
or that a composer intuitively
or purposefully will kind
of intimate, especially with
a solo violin or a solo cello.
They'll put in things
so that we fill in lines
where it is possible necessarily
to have continuous lines.
So it's kind of taking advantage
of a psychology of
music perception.
Other composers have done this,
especially with the
case of text.
And what I mean by
that is that --
one of the most clear ones
would be with sacred music
when composers will put in, say,
biblical quotes or something
like that, that are not
articulated in any way.
Perhaps this is an
instrumental work.
Liszt does this all the time.
Brahms does this in the
Second Piano Sonata.
He puts the words to a song
above the second movement.
>> But the song is not heard.
>> David Plylar: But
we don't hear the song.
You hear some of the melody
and the player sees it,
but the person listening,
unless they are looking
over the shoulder of the
performer, isn't aware of it.
And so I call this
[inaudible] text.
And there's a lot
of that going on.
And it can be very interesting
because it what it implies is
that there's more to a
relationship with a work of art
than just passively
taking it in.
You can actively
kind of contribute
to your experience by, you know,
working with the
score or however else.
>> Thank you very much.
>> I was curious about the
term "humoresque" because sort
of in my mind I expected
a shorter piece.
But I wondered generally
what the implication
of that term would be.
>> David Plylar: So
that's a tough one to cover
because before Schumann did
this piece, I don't know
of any other musical
work that has this title.
He was very interested in Jean
Paul [phonetic] and other people
who were writing and
doing interesting work
with this aesthetics
and basically literary
theory and things like that.
I don't have it in front
of me but there's a quote
from Schumann saying that
as he is writing this,
he feels simultaneously
overjoyed
and deep sadness
at the same time.
I the idea of an
ironic sort of humor,
in that it's not just a
knee-slapper type of joking
that he is trying to do,
but rather, you know,
he uses like terms
"with humor' in lots
of his other works
at different points.
So he is kind of tapping into
an adjective that he uses,
but again, what's interesting
about those is the contrast
between the moments
that have that marking
and what comes before
and what comes after.
It's some sort of switch
that happens in the character
of the piece, and that's the
best way I can describe what I
think is happening.
And so I think it's rather than
fleeting passage of moods rather
than the happy-go-lucky sort of
thing that maybe you would think
that that title implies.
>> So in terms of
the quotations,
we know that in the literary
world they do analyses
of word patterns and
use of certain words,
and I'm wondering --
to determine if a piece
is by the same author,
they've done this to Shakespeare
and some manuscripts.
I'm wondering if there's
a similar situation
with musicians.
Is there like a fingerprint
of certain ways of phrasing?
>> David Plylar:
That's a good question.
It's one that's actually
still relevant today.
I can't remember
who the parties were
but just a few days ago I was
reading that somebody settled
on what seemed to be
too much of a closeness
between two pop songs.
One that was written
a long time ago
and one had just been composed.
And the two parties settled.
One other example from
the pop world would be
"Under Pressure"
and "Ice Ice Baby."
I don't know if you know this.
Those two are extremely close
and which one's copying
the other.
And those are actually
legal questions
that are hard to answer.
Sometimes people win
and it makes sense.
Sometimes people when and
it doesn't make sense.
But what you're talking
about is, I think,
more of a historical
marker or determining
if a piece is authentically
related to a given composer.
And there are people who just
to know a particular composer
inside and out so much
that they can say with a
certain degree of certainty
that a work is authentic or not.
But really, it takes
a specialist.
I'm sure there are people who
have algorithmic processes
for exploring these things.
I don't know about them
personally but I'm sure
that people are doing
that as part of analysis.
Again, a lot of the
types of connections
that one can make are not
just based on the parameters
that you might initially
expect to have in place.
Just like just an aural
perimeter or just a visual one.
So it's hard.
I don't think it's ever
going to be possible
to take away the human
element of being able
to parse things in
a particular way.
>> Speaking of hidden messages,
there are often times in music,
words actually spelled
like Dimitri Shostakovich
with the DE flat and so on.
And so the same is
true for Bach.
And I think Brahms did that too,
and the story just
slips my mind.
I think he had a
woman that he admired
in Gottingham [phonetic] named
Agnes, and he did a motif on AG.
I don't know what did
for N, then e flat.
Can you verify that?
>> David Plylar: This
is a common practice.
I mean, one of the most
famous examples is Bach.
So what she's speaking of is
Bach, who the B would be B flat
in the way of our nomenclature.
A would be A. C would be C
and H would be B natural.
And so, you have
something similar happening.
Shostakovich would do
this with his name.
Because of the Germanic spelling
of particular note names
and that's how you
get the initials,
people do this all the time.
I think you're thinking
of the Agnes [Inaudible]
something like that.
That doesn't sound right to
me actually, now as I say it.
But yeah, this was a
game that people played.
Schumann played it very
prominently in the [Inaudible],
the movements from "Carnaval,"
the sphinxes that spell
out little names that
are of meaning to him.
And then we have
interpreters now,
170 years later,
trying to figure out.
"Well, do I play that
in concert or do I just,
you know, go past it?"
but sometimes those things
can be kind of musical keys.
I think that Shostakovich
thought of it that way,
in the sense that it
provides some sort
of mode of entry into a work.
And certainly it does for
Bach, because when you look
at those permutations
[inaudible], you do kind of feel
like that it's an interesting
enough motif to be worthy
of Bach, and so [inaudible].
>> [Inaudible] Brahms?
>> David Plylar: Yeah, so Brahms
never -- he said, you know,
there are two things that he
never tried, opera and marriage.
So he had different interests,
but nothing ever in the end lead
to marriage or things.
But he certainly had interests.
>> In terms of quotes,
I wondered --
you made a comment about
how one of Brahms' quotes
that you cited was demonstrating
a different orchestral quality
and sort of texture.
I wonder if that or other
examples of these have anything
to do with advances
in the instrument
from one to the other?
Or was it such a short period
of time, it didn't matter?
>> David Plylar: Absolutely.
I should say yes and no.
I'm not an expert on
this by any stretch,
but eventually you're having
the expansion of the size
of the keyboard so that
you're adding a base.
And eventually it even goes
lower than your typical Grand.
You have the Bosendorfer
Imperial Grand
that has a few extra
notes on the very bottom.
Even today, that's still
not entirely standard,
although it generally is
with 88 keys, as you know.
But you have different factors
that go into the construction
of the piano and control
that the performer has,
especially performer/composers
that absolutely needs them
to exploring different types
of things compositionally.
By the time you have
Brahms in the 1850s kind
of pounding away a bit, you've
got more sizable instruments
than early Chopin
and Mendelssohn would
have been working with.
I think then they kind
of rise to the occasion.
For instance, I can give you
-- and I'll stop talking --
but one clear example
would be the difference
between a piano that's light
to the touch and a piano
that is heavy to the touch.
In the 19th century, in general,
pianos had a lighter touch.
And so you have certain pieces,
especially some of, let's say,
Liszt's etudes, that
are much more possible
on those instruments and
making it really quite --
I'm thinking of [Inaudible]
for instance,
one of the "Transcendental
Etudes."
It's quite an interesting
feat to see somebody playing
that on a modern Steinway.
But of course, the pianists
are also trained and brought
up to -- they're living
now, so they're working
with what we have now and they
have so many different resources
with modern instruments that
those types of differences --
they are if you find it.
People treating those
instruments
differently [inaudible].
Especially with before we were
doing stuff inside the pianos
and things like that.
I don't know if I
answered your question.
Okay, I think I'm done.
I have been rambling a bit.
But thanks so much, and I
hope you enjoy the show.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.